hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and
right now i'm doing youtube videos
because guys i want to pass the
knowledge i know
that a lot of you are getting fresh
interest in the stock market and you are
wondering
who you can trust what kind of
techniques are working actually what is
efficient what tools you can use
and you don't know where to find the
proper information and guys that's why
i'm here i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you how portrayed is
actually working and what is working for
me
so if you want to know about all this
stuff you are in the right place
so today i want to make an update on
gamestop gme
let's get into it
[Music]
first let's have a quick look at what
happened uh in the past
days all right so i've gone the daily
time frame and i can see that basically
oh
we had a strong move up around 50 so
this was last
week this was on the 24th of february
the stock took like
around 100 and guys very interesting
look what we had here
so okay you're gonna this was a fake
breakout it was not easy to play but
whatever
let me tell you guys that why this level
acted as
support i didn't do videos on gamestop
so i cannot tell you that i told you
but as usual guys you connect the two
recent
highs that are in the direction of the
trend so here
one two so i'm a ten year time frame i
could do it here as well and
it would have worked but now this is
finished here is same thing i connect
this one and this one and look
here breakout retest then we go higher
it's always like this guys this is done
now this is behind us and the new one is
this one
so breakout retest we go higher so
this was our support level and here on
the daily time frame you could have
been stopped because i like to use stop
plus stop losses because i'm a
professional trader this is how we do
this we manage the risk we do we don't
just buy
calls and hope they're going to finish
in the money actually i prefer to buy
code spreads but this is not the
discussion here
and then i can leave the code spread
without stop plus but if i buy futures
guys no way i don't use a stop-loss when
i buy futures or i buy just you know
delta one
product like i said now we are doing the
new wave so i'm gonna come back to
technicals very soon let's go to the
news quickly
so the first thing i like to watch is
the short interest so market watch is up
to date now it's updated
every two weeks guys so this is the data
from the 12th of february
so 30 of uh showed interest so guys this
is still
a lot and the train is bullish so i
think that all the people who are short
so means hedge funds
considering where they're gonna stop the
position so there could be some more
insane move if we break the whole time
highs and i think we're gonna do
because guys i think we're on a bubble
but not at the end of the bubble at the
beginning of the bubble
the reasons behind i explained this very
well guys on my
in my videos on snp and nasdaq bubbles
so please go check it out and you're
gonna see my views you're gonna be
pretty shocked
and i have some indicators that will
tell me if this is actually not
happening or not for now
it's happening all right so if it's
happening gamestop is gonna
go above this level i'm gonna go back to
technicals and give you my targets but
trust me that if we break these levels
the shorts
the short squeeze is gonna happen again
what kind of
news we can find so i like to go on
yahoo finance and check the news
so i can find uh you know the first one
australian cam from
reddit gainer stays for long-term growth
so i'm not going to go through the
details of this article but
i read it and it's basically saying that
some uh you know professionals
went to a gamestop to make some
short-term profits and actually they
were like oh
but actually i want to keep it for the
long term so this is very good
for this company guys you know you have
this uh in this
interest that is coming from everywhere
and people get uh you know
have a look at the company's
fundamentals and they actually like it
and they keep it so this is a very good
news for me
then uh we have the staff i told i
talked about it yesterday already in my
amc video so the social tracking
buzz etfs so basically it's an
asset manager van eck that just created
on the 4th of march
this etf that is basically containing
all the hot stocks
guys this is perfect you know they are
very smart to do it
i think that this is very good news for
all these hot stocks so basically
this stocks are the ark stocks you know
managed by
kathy rude she actually i think is the
source of all this
stuff fubo socket mobile
amc gme uh clvs all this stuff
is actually something that kathy wood
is very bullish on so what else do we
have oh very interesting guys i was
talking uh to you about
this guy so you must know him for sure i
mean if you're watching my video you
probably
watched his so this guy is genius you
know just for everyone
to see what i think you know because
some people were telling me oh luke
when he's talking about him he's like
you know looks angry or whatever no
i admire this guy what he did is amazing
but he's facing some difficulties i
think it's going to be fine for him
because he is at the origin of what
happened on gamestop
and uh he needed to speak he got a
subpoena
and he needed to speak in front of the
congress testify and explain you know
his activities
on gamestop you know because he was
posting that he was long and he
basically created
uh the beginning of this uh rally and
the only
news that we have here it is it is that
actually he was a broker she was
actually working in the finance industry
before
so while trading in gamestop jill worked
as mass mutual marketing and financial
education job
and was registered financial broker in
massachusetts
but you know brokers that don't have
inside information so he's going to be
fine
he just you know did something very good
and
he didn't have any the question he had
is if this guy had some inside
information
did he know some stuff that he shouldn't
and that he shared with people to
for his own interest this is the
questions that try to answer
and for now definitely they don't have
anything
and that's why i'm pretty confident
everything is going to be fine for him
but let's see if like some news happen
so and to conclude on the technicals
guys do you want some targets i'm gonna
give you some targets all right like i
said i'm very bullish
on everything basically guys because of
the flow of money
uh because of the you know bullish
sentiment that is coming
from everywhere in the world from all
the bubble signals that we have
and once again go watch my videos i
explained this very well smp bubble
nasdaq bubble
and if we are in a bubble then
everything is just gonna go
much much higher especially the hot
stocks so what is then happening
is that usually you just measure the
first wave so first wave is here
okay you measure this
and you use fib extensions and this is
giving you targets so
first wave is done one we did the two
so now we are in the third wave so like
i said
we don't know if actually the third wave
is going to go through all-time highs i
mean nothing
side not all-time highs but recent highs
but i'm pretty convinced and if we do
we're going to have a new short squeeze
so it makes sense for me that we go to
the 1.618 because the number ratio the
most likely one to happen
the one that is followed by all the
professionals and i think that you know
people are just going to cut the
position
above 400. so for me this new wave has
started
so it's going to go there so my target
is 800
you know around 800 on gamestop for the
coming you know
year something i guess all right guys
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video
i hope i managed to explain to you guys
uh how i find my information and how i
use it to make
some to find some targets and some entry
level and set up my trades
and if you did enjoy this video please
don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i see you guys